Victoria Nuland
reacted coolly to the news that her
phone call about Ukraine with another
top US diplomat had seeped out I'm
obviously not going to comment on
private diplomatic conversations other
than to say it was pretty impressive
tradecraft the audio was extremely clear
someone uploaded to YouTube an audio
recording of a phone conversation Nuland
had last month with the US ambassador to
Ukraine Jeff Pyatt she said she would
welcome UN involvement in resolving
Ukraine's crisis and followed that with
an expletive the disparage that you use
efforts exactly she has now apologized
for her choice of words the State
Department spokeswoman said Nuland had
called her European partners to express
regret but she also attacked Russia for
its alleged role on the link we think
this is a new low and Russian tradecraft
in terms of publicizing posting I don't
have any other independent details about
the origin of the YouTube video you're
right this is clearly happened overnight
and is relatively new but this is
something they've been actively
promoting posting on tweeting about
Nuland is Washington's top diplomat on
European affairs responsible for mending
fences with the EU in the wake of the
NSA spy scandal a job that could have
just turned a lot harder